These two gentlemen, Diffie and Helmann, actually came up with an idea, and they published
a paper called New Directions in Cryptography.
In this module, we're going to describe asymmetric key cryptography and how it works, so if you
remember to what the advantages and disadvantages of symmetric cryptography are, it's very fast,
but it has this problem of key distribution.
People have been thinking about this problem of key distribution for thousands of years.
And in 1976, these two gentlemen, Diffie and Helmann, actually came up with an idea,
and they published a paper called New Directions in Cryptography, because they talked about
how there might be a different way to do cryptography that gets rid of the problem of key distribution.
And so they published a paper called New Directions in Cryptography, and within it, they actually
described this process, and they actually called it public key cryptography, and that's
why a lot of people still call it that today.
But it should really be called asymmetric key cryptography, and what they went on to describe
basically is that they said, okay, if you think about symmetric, you know, we need the
same key at both ends, and that requires key distribution, which in many cases is a very
big problem.
So they went on to describe how, what if everybody has two keys instead of one?
So I would have my own two keys.
You would have your own two keys.
This person over here has their own two keys.
Everybody has a key pair.
But most importantly, the two keys, for example that I have, are related to each other
mathematically.
There's a mathematical relationship that links my two keys together.
The idea is, if I use one to encrypt, you can never use the same one to decrypt.
It's not possible.
You have to use the other one.
And the reason this works is because the two are linked mathematically.
So if I use this one to encrypt, it's this one that decrypts.
If I use this one to encrypt, it's this other one that decrypts.
You can never encrypt and decrypt with the same key.
So the idea is, I'm going to take one of my keys and I'm going to give it to anyone, the
whole world possibly, that may want to communicate with me securely.
And because I'm going to give that key to anyone who may want to communicate with me securely,
I'm going to call that one my public key.
So the entire world may have my public key.
But if anyone wants to communicate with me securely, a secret message, let's say, they
will encrypt that message with my public key.
And even though everyone else has my public key, nobody can read that message because you
can never encrypt and decrypt with the same key, it has to be the other one.
So if anyone out there encrypts a message with my public key, the only key that can decrypt
is the other key that I keep private to myself.
This key, I will never disclose, communicate, divulge or send to anyone else.
I will always keep it private to myself.
That's why I'm going to call that my private key.
So this solves the problem of key distribution, doesn't it?
Because the only key that I ever have to distribute is my public key and I don't care how many
people have it.
In fact, I can assume that the entire world has my public key.
As long as I keep my other private key that is associated with it, private to myself,
it's very important to keep the private key private to myself, never disclose it, communicate
it, and so on.
This solves the problem of key distribution, but it actually introduces another problem
that is pretty substantial.
And that is the only way that this works is because the two keys are related to each
other mathematically.
So if I give my public key out to the entire world, I've got to make sure that nobody
out there can use my public key and compute the mathematical relationship that links my
two keys together.
Because if that was possible, anybody out there that has my public key will be able to
compute the relationship and therefore derive knowledge of my private key by having access
to my public key.
And so we have to be able to prevent that.
And the only way that we can prevent this is to use or to link the two keys together
using really hard math and use really large numbers in that hard math.
The idea is whoever has my public key may be able to compute what the relationship is.
But because we are using hard math and very large numbers, given today's technology in
our speed of processors, it would take that person hundreds of years in order to be able
to compute as long as we're using really large numbers to link the two keys together.
And so it's possible.
But because we're using really large numbers, it's not feasible and no one's even going
to try because it's going to take too much computational power to derive knowledge.
And one of the issues that we have with asymmetric key cryptography is as processors become faster
and technology improves, guess what we have to do?
We have to keep increasing the size of those numbers that link the two keys together.
The problem is this because we have to use hard math and really large numbers.
This becomes computationally intensive and therefore there's a price to pay.
The price to pay is that this type of cryptography becomes really slow as a result because of
that mathematical intensity that links the two keys together.
So because we're using really large numbers, it's going to take a really long time to encrypt
and decrypt with the two.
That's what the price is.
But if you look at this, it does solve the problem of key distribution, but it makes this
type of cryptography really slow.
So if you remember the advantages of symmetric, very fast, but it has the problem of key distribution.
This is the actual opposite, isn't it?
Solves the problem of key distribution, but becomes very slow.
And that's why the two are really complementary to each other.
And we'll talk about that later on, but most cryptography solutions today end up being
a combination of symmetric and asymmetric for what they're each good at.
Symmetric is typically used for bulk and speed and asymmetric is used to exchange the symmetric
keys that are required in both ends in order to be able to do things quickly.
So today we have hybrid products, crypto systems that really combine symmetric algorithms
and asymmetric together to be able to use them both for what they're really good at.
So in summary, when you look at the advantages and disadvantages of asymmetric, it's going
to be the opposite of what we had for symmetric.
The advantage is that it solves the problem of key distribution, but it becomes really
slow.
Now one of the other problems that we had with symmetric was the scalability problem.
If you add a whole bunch of people that need it to communicate securely with each other
using symmetric key cryptography, the number of keys required was going to grow exponentially.
In fact, I think we used an example of 1,000 people needing to communicate securely with
each other, would require almost half a million keys.
Well, this type of cryptography also solves the problem of scalability, because if we have
1,000 people that need to communicate securely with each other, all that's required is a total
of 2,000 keys, because every person has their key pair, private and public key.
So 1,000 people total of 2,000 keys, that's a whole lot easier to manage than obviously
almost half a million keys.
So there are advantages and disadvantages to this, but that's why it makes sense to use
them together, symmetric and asymmetric.
So here's a slide that talks about how this works.
And what you need to focus on here is that you start seeing how this type of cryptography
actually provides some added advantages that we didn't have before with symmetric.
But if you want to address confidentiality, what needs to happen here is the person sending
me, for example, a secret message, will have to encrypt that message with my public key.
To address confidentiality, you will always encrypt with the receiver's public key.
All right, so it's the public key of the receiver that allows us to achieve confidentiality,
because then the receiver will have to use their private key, which nobody else has.
And so that ensures confidentiality of the message.
You will always encrypt with the receiver's public key.
Now here's something else though that we can achieve.
So if you remember, let's say that I am going to encrypt a message with my private key,
my private key.
Who can read that message?
Well, it's going to be anybody that has my public key, which I have to assume is the
entire world.
So why would I ever do that?
Why would I ever encrypt a message with my private key, knowing that anyone out there
that has my public key will be able to read that message?
Because that obviously does not address confidentiality.
Well here's the answer to that.
If I encrypt a message with my private key and all of you can decrypt it with what you
know is my public key, that proves to you where it came from.
And so we're starting to address possibly something that's very important to address
in today's environment.